50 million dollars in gourd gold bars in
august as cash pile grows so this is a
cnbc story while some companies such as
tesla are diversifying into bitcoin data
analytics software company palantirs
betting on gold palantir about 50
million dollars in gold bars in august
the company disclosed in its latest
earnings statement the move reflects a
growing company stashing cash in an
unconventional asset in response to
economic uncertainty spurred by the
coronavirus pandemic in government's
response to the price of an ounce of
gold crossed two thousand dollars marked
for the first time last year as a
pandemic worsened and us government
stimulus efforts continued the years
this year's investors have more loudly
voice concerns about inflation and gold
is sometimes viewed as a hedge against
inflation although prices are down seven
percent for the year some investors have
thought cryptocurrency might also serve
that role thoughts ah this scares the
living hell out of me because when you
say pound tear yeah it's really peter
thiel who's one of the most brilliant
investors of all time libertarian guys
yes um
they
are doing this for what they say uh in
the in the event of a black swan event a
a global catastrophe they're also uh for
the record they are incredibly bullish
on on bitcoin and crypto as well but
this is why it scares me because peter
thiel is almost never wrong he's always
ahead of trend and palantir specifically
exists for one reason they are a
predictive analytics fund that helps
governments and fortune 100 companies
be ready for the future so if their
predictive analytics are saying we need
to stockpile
resources in event of this global
catastrophe that scares the hell out of
me because that's not your crazy uncle
with a tin foil hat that's somebody
that's been proven right again and again
and again well i will say this i think
it there's a companies are hoarding cash
right now that we did a story yesterday
on vtpost.com the top six largest
companies in the world that aren't
financial firms are sitting on seven
trillion in cash right now so there it
has to be put somewhere and i'm just
wondering a is 50 billion how much is
the 15 million is 50 million really that
much compared to how much cash
in gold though yeah but i think it's
just another angle they put it in and
but that's 50 million today though tom
like that that is a set asset amount
that 50 million in gold could very well
be 500 million in gold
the same amount could appreciate it's
true now now gold is down right a little
bit this year seven percent i think it's
down for the year but it's always gonna
have value it's gonna go up and down and
it won't be a bad investment but my
initial thought was
they're sitting on billions and 50
million is just what they put into one
aspect of it and it gets a lot of
publicity because it sounds like a lot
and then were they going to store it i
heard somewhere are they going to store
it somewhere in the northeast i'm very
nervous about storing gold yeah if they
if they tell us david yeah right we
should go yeah well let's look at this
kai can you find out how much cash is
does palantir sit on right now right
there okay uh as of march 31st of 2021
they're sitting on two point three eight
billion dollars so two point eight three
two point three eight billion dollars if
we do
uh
uh two point let's do the math here 50
million
divided by
2.8 uh 2.38
billion let's take a look at this what
this percentage is
it's really zero two percent it's
nothing they're just diversifying it's
not uh
if it was ten percent if it was twenty
percent that's legit if you're doing
point zero two percent it's kinda like
you got a million dollars like yeah the
advisor says i think you should put
fifty thousand dollars in the you know
uh what do you call it precious metals
okay cool let's do fifty thousand
dollars i think that's kind of what the
positioning is i don't see it as
anything more than that gold quite
frankly i have gold uh and i have crypto
and gold doesn't come anywhere near what
uh crypto has done but the purpose of
buying gold is very different than the
purpose of buying
investment stocks or crypto it's a very
different philosophy of why you buy gold
gold
gold if we ever go gold standard what's
the likelihood of us ever going back to
gold standard zero it's it's like point
zero zero zero zero one percent right
okay so they say well if we go back to
gold standard like you know
it's gonna go from two thousand to half
a million dollars come on now you sound
like the same guy that says bitcoin is
going to go to a million by the end of
the year right it's the same exact uh uh
uh marketing strategy that people are
using but this is simply i think you
ought to have a small percentage of
money in gold and uh
precious metals and that's probably what
these guys are doing i don't think it's
anything more than that so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you